if you had any complaints about horizon  zero dawn the latest patch just might  put you at ease I'm Tony and this is  your fixed gamespot news update as far  as new features the horizon patch adds  an option to buy multiple items by  holding X and the ability to invert the  x axis good changes if you're a big fan  of the 24th letter of the alphabet the  patch also tweaks the drop rate of  certain items and adjust the AI for both  human characters and the Robo dinos  we've got the full list of patch notes  and bug fixes up on gamespot so be sure  to subscribe for all the latest on a  Lloyd's adventure if you've already  finished horizon zero dawn you'll be  happy to know that developer Guerrilla  Games is working on a story expansion  and speaking of stories why not check  out our deep dive into bioware's latest  with the story of mass effect  [Music]  you  [Music]